everyone knows that the right-wing
extremism in this country has targeted
democratically ran cities who does the
mayor of Chicago blame for the problems
of a Democrat run City for the last 80
years where everyone's getting shot
you're not going to believe it and you
are going to believe it well it has to
be better coordination you know what
we've seen is a very raggedy form um
instituted by right-wing extrem
extremism um everyone knows that the
right-wing extremism in this country has
targeted democratically ran cities and
quite frankly uh they've been very
intentional about going after
democratically ran cities that are led
by people of color and their whole
motivation is to create disruption and
Chaos because that's what this that
particular party has been about right
this is the same political party that
did not want to accept that President
Obama was actually an American it's the
same Republican right-wing extremism
that stormed the capital it's the same
right-wing extremism that refuses to
accept the results of the the Civil War
it's raggedy it's disrespectful it's
mean-spirited it's an unclean Spirit
quite frankly and so so I got you I got
I just want to make sure that people
understand what we're facing that's why
it's so important that the faith
community is leaning in In This Moment
guys guys guys guys it's not the 80
years of democrat rule in Chicago and
Illinois it's not Lori Lightfoot before
him it's not this guy it's not any of
the economic conditions or what they've
done with homeless or drugs or any of
that stuff they have all the laws by the
way to stop people from getting guns but
people still get them one way or another
right cuz bad people do bad things it's
not any of that it's that mean
Republicans these these freaking
Republicans keep talking about it why do
they keep they are just always focused
on all of the black kids that are shot
here and
if